Jay Bilas joining us here on the Rich
Eisen show as promised how are you Jay
rich how are you I am hanging in there
thank you so very much let's get right
down to it then you were you are part of
the worldwide leader in sports draft
analysis it is now the draft analysis
season now that we know who gets to
choose where what do you think the
Phoenix Suns are going to do with that
first overall pick Jay Bilas I don't
know that Phoenix means there's not one
player that's going to make Phoenix a
contender so they need pillars that are
gonna they're going to be able to build
on for a long period of time so you can
make a case I don't think there's a
no-brainer
LeBron type player in this draft or he
said okay clear number one and everybody
else is number two three and four I do
think that DeAndre Aiden of Arizona is
the top prospect in the draft but I
think you could make a credible case
especially considering how well Phoenix
knows Luca Dante the Slovenian kid is
playing for Real Madrid that you know in
today's game having a 6/8 guard that can
it can really pass the ball and the ball
will move with him in the game you could
you could put a high high value on that
and he's he's young with with experience
way beyond his years I'm quite against
men for so long
playing in Europe so to me it would be
between those two I would go with Aiden
but but that's just me I mean Aiden's
like a prototype power forward an NBA
that can step away and knock down threes
and play with his back to the basket run
at finish plays I mean he's the real
deal but there's a good case to be made
for Dodgers as well well yeah obviously
the fans would know eight and more up
close and personal in that regard but I
I imagine that's not the reason why a
team should go ahead and make a trade
cuz you know the Suns fans could fall in
love with da itch the minute he shows up
right so oh yeah I don't think you go
like I think teams have made mistakes
going with you know sort of the local
kids thinking well it's gonna sell
tickets and that last for all of about
15 minutes you know I remember with New
York everybody was so disappointed with
kristaps porzingis and and
he's been in his biggest fan favorite as
you could possibly have hopefully he'll
come back healthy and and fulfill the
promise he showed because he's proven to
be the real deal and when I watched him
on film I wasn't sure about him what
sure about his body and all these
different things in the NBA it proved to
be he really was a unicorn as far as how
successful he was right away
the Knicks choosing 9th overall and then
you got the Clippers at 12th and 13th
Denver 14 15 who do you think is the pop
now if I ask you this question last year
you probably weren't going to spit out
the name of Donovan Mitchell anyway but
who do you think could be that guy this
year coming out that is sort of a mid
round pick up that has the opportunity
to be a rookie of the year dynamo
rookies a year I don't know I don't know
that it's not very often you see that
usually Rookie of the Year comes out of
the top seven but you know I'm a big fan
I like Lonnie Walker from Miami one he's
got great hair and there's a great kid
he's the guy that watches more Animal
Planet's than basketball but he's he was
had some injury issues to start the year
so got off to a slower start maybe
didn't show how good that he can be
early on in the year but made some big
shots throughout the year super athletic
you know I do like Dyer Smith the kid
from Texas Tech but he's a longer term
player he's a ridiculous athlete kind of
in the Donovan Mitchell realm but he's
not as polished of a player because he's
a lot younger
the guy rich that I think is going to be
the most interesting player in the draft
as to how you process sort of how good
he is versus what he's been through and
and and his body is going to be Michael
Porter jr. that kid out of Missouri who
could be like he could have been healthy
and if he'd come right out of high
school you would have said a man he
might be the one or to pick that that's
how talented he is but he got injured he
had surgery played all two minutes at
the start of the year for Missouri and
didn't come back and feel like the SEC
Tournament when he was out of shape and
and didn't show very well so there are a
lot of kind of question marks you know
it's not often you say well we have to
find out what the doctors say and then
we'll get to the basketball part
the doctors say iffy if there are no red
flags on his medical he's a top top pre
talent that could wind up going 8 9 10
that that's where I would guess and I'm
just guessing that you're kind of saying
you know what that might be the work the
risk at 9:00 to be able to get a top 3
talent at 9:10 if you follow that bar
but who knows maybe somebody will take
them at 3 or 4 and then you get a player
that falls to further down that you
wouldn't expect it otherwise of course
that plays out later in June Jay Bilas
here in the Rich Eisen show I would be
remiss Jay if I did not ask how the news
of sports gambling about to become so
much more prevalent on the state level
I'll hit you when you heard to how the
NCAA might have its hand out when it all
comes down to it what are your thoughts
on that Jay you know Richard probably
that my first thought was that what my
grandfather would have thought when
Prohibition was repealed you know sort
of the idea that everybody's doing this
anyway why are we why are we prohibiting
this and I make that comparison because
you know there are a lot of bad things
that come along with was alcohol but
most of society handles it and handles
it pretty well and we manage it and and
it's and I look at gambling the same way
sort of as I don't want to say harmless
vice but for most people it is harmless
like no I don't think the feds are gonna
come after me on this but like you know
I bet I've got a football pool with my
friends for 20 bucks a week and it makes
the games more interesting and you know
the emails that go back and forth when
there's a backdoor cover you know Monday
Night Football it's fun and and games
that I would have been interested in
otherwise I'm interested in and we do
the same thing with the majors in golf
and we throw a few bucks in and
everybody picks players and and it makes
it more enjoyable and and I think that's
the way it is for the overwhelming
majority of people who are interested
sports but in terms of the college
football though or basketball if a kid
is playing sport that now I guess the
the governing body is going to have
maybe wetting their beak a little bit I
mean does that give fuel to your eye
of paying the players Jencks everything
gives fuel to that rich I mean I as the
money grows whether it's whether it's
coming from television or merchandising
or apparel licensing deals or just the
apparel deals you have for the teams
it's just that the the big gap between
amateurism and the billions of dollars
that are the game are going to make that
argument what we're having that anyway
so when you add in the gambling portion
of the additional revenue streams
they're these games they're you know
life sports whether it's college or pro
is going to continue to make money and
and look I uh lis think that my way of
viewing this even though reasonable
Minds could differ that my way of doing
this is going to come to pass whether it
comes to pass in the next ten years or
in our lifetimes I don't know but but
amateurism isn't going to survive
well billions of dollars are being made
off these players that's just not gonna
it's not going to be sustained long term
but you know I'm sure people in the 30s
said the same thing it's still going
there they're in trouble he's gonna
fight tooth and nail to keep to keep
their ability to keep all the money but
but we've already seen named images like
this is coming I mean the Commission on
the Rights Commission even Condoleezza
Rice is out there saying that the name
is image and likeness should belong to
the players and when that step is taken
it's not far behind what the schools are
going to go you know what we need to
control this so we should just pay them
so that they're not out cutting all
these side deals that may be counter to
what we're doing
and how'd you do in your fantasy and
your football pool J you know it depends
on the year
it i I do surprisingly well some years I
can tell you that what we do is we throw
a few bucks in each week and you have to
pick two games against the spread but
you have to win them both to get into
the money and it's surprisingly how hard
that is to do it sounds really easy but
but but man those guys in the as
restatements calls of our friends and
arid regions they know what they're
doing it is hard is hard to pick those
things to pick up correctly good thing
you've got your dude too great Jay
thanks for the call appreciate it
always a pleasure rich thank you you
know that's Jay Bilas the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience